tout de suite ton jette un coup d’œil à
la presse avec vous Hélène frad bonjour
Hélène bonjour Pauline on va commencer
bien sûr avec vous à regarder les
premières une même s'il est tard aux
États-Unis et tôt en réalité dans le
processus de de dépouillement première
analyser analyse de la première une et
analyse de la presse sur les mythermes
aux États-Unis là on est fait on a assez
peu d'éléments pour le moment du côté de
la presse en d'autant que vous l'avez
dit les résultats restent extrêmement
serrés à l'instant où on parle tellement
serré d'ailleurs que
USA Today redoute que c'est mitters ne
fassent finalement qu'amplifier les
bruits les tensions qui divisent déjà
l'Amérique le Washington Times quotidien
conservateur en fait en tout cas déjà
état d'une probable victoire des
républicains à la Chambre des
Représentants on l'a dit trop tôt pour
l'instant pour le confirmer mais ce qui
est absolument incontestable c'est cette
série de victoires pas surprenante mais
très symbolique pour les républicains en
Floride où ils font littéralement carton
plat le Miami Herald annonce en effet la
réélection de Maria Elvira Salazar à la
Chambre des Représentants celle du
sénateur Marco Rubio ainsi que celle de
Ron De Santis au poste de gouverneur à
cette figure majeure du parti
républicain s'affirme comme un potentiel
rival pour Donald Trump à la prochaine
primaire républicaine pour la
présidentielle de 2024 et sa victoire
est-elle que le Wall Street Journal
évoque que ce matin un tsunami de Santis
le journal indique que le gouverneur a
gagné presque partout dans l'État de
Floride y compris dans des bascules dans
des bastions des mots clés si on
entendait tout à l'heure l'un de ceux
qui pourraient compliquer 2024 pour
Donald Trump en y reviendra les mystère
américaine Hélène qui inspire beaucoup
les dessinateurs de presse dans le
dessin de deux à deux pour le Washington
Post un client qui ressemble beaucoup à
Joe Biden d'ailleurs présente son
ordonnance à la Pharmacia on frôle la
rupture la rupture de stock il faut dire
que ces était un vrai casse-tête et
bonne pour les affaires des pharmaciens
plus d'antis douleurs plus
d'antidépresseurs et plus de pilules
contre le stress dans celui de montemore
l'un pour de Times un éléphant
républicain écrase littéralement Joe
Biden dans le bureau Val encore deux ans
à tenir indique la légende un plus que
deux ans avant la présidentielle la
présidentielle de 2024 sur laquelle
pleine déjà on l'a beaucoup évoqué
l'ombre de Donald Trump avoir avec ce
dessin de Chapatte pour le journal
suisse Le Temps ça se couvre comme un
électeur Donald Trump dont la chevelure
se confond avec l'éléphant républicain
dans ce beau dessin de Ramsès publié par
le site cartoon movement
à travers la presse un mois à présent de
l'annonce officielle aujourd'hui de la
fin de l'opération barcale annonce faite
par Emmanuel Macron ce mercredi et après
9 ans d'existence l'opération française
vit ces dernières heures mais l'annonce
de la fin de barkhane
suffit pas pour autant le départ des
troupes françaises et c'est ce que
rappelle le pays qui annonce que cette
décision sera sans conséquence sur le
dispositif militaire actuel au Sahel
dans la région ou 3000 soldats sont
toujours déployés au Niger au Tchad et
au Burkina Faso le quotidien burkinabè
explique que l'opération cherche
désormais à opérer SAMU pour ne plus
être perçu comme une force d'occupation
outre la fin de barkhane Damien Emmanuel
Macron présentera aujourd'hui aussi les
grands axes de sa politique de défense
pour les années à venir d'après le
quotidien La Croix qui rapporte que
l'armée française après des années de
restriction budgétaire n'est plus
dimensionnée pour un conflit de haute
intensité à ses frontières comme ce qui
se passe actuellement en Ukraine et puis
le mot de la fin Hélène avant de vous
dire à tout à l'heure Pauline rapide
coup d'oeil à l'équipe qui donne le top
départ de la Route du Rhum la douzième
édition débute finalement cet après-midi
avec trois jours trop tard elle a
rubrique cheveux au vent toujours à
bille le transition n'est-ce pas dans la
catégorie musicale cette fois cet
article du gardien qui a retenu
l'attention de Damien coquet le journal
annonce le grand retour du style heavy
metal pour résumer ses cheveux longs et
pais des courtes mais cuire tout de cuir
vêtu je vous laisse se voir ça plus en
détail avec cette photo
ravissante notez le ravissant eau ajouré
je ne poussais assorti à la moustache
super vous n'aurez pas dû passer à côté
de ça Hélène merci beaucoup
n'est-ce pas à tout à l'heure